et à plusieurs mois si ma notification
de beau cette reprise est donc jeudi une
précaution que
quand c'est bientôt la rentrée voilà une
aide en fait pour pouvoir rester pour
une humidité d'un moment cette étudiante
guadeloupéenne fait sa rentrée en bts à
bellevue et ce en bourse
ces études pourraient semblait
compromise heureusement les aides
proposées aux étudiants ont peu fortuné
devrait l'aider à persister dans la voie
qu'elle a choisie
vu que ma situation particulière je
pense que oui effectivement j'ai une
petite baisse du yen
donc je pense que je vais pouvoir
montceau retient fait bien entendre oui
ça fait du bien parce qu'on n'est pas de
la martinique on est sollicité on a
besoin de quelqu'un pour assurer
justement pour parce que je veux pas
arrêter mes études aide financière
conseils pour établir son budget le claj
reçoit chaque année des milliers
d'étudiants
alors si aujourd'hui la situation des
jeunes et de plus en plus précaire
les parements dernières n'ont pas tous
joué effectivement le moyen de les
soutenir financièrement
aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment chercher les solutions pour
leur apporter les aides disponibles les
dispositifs les orienter vers les
dispositifs qui existent et ne pas les
laisser partir comme ça non plus dans la
nature parce qu'il ya des études c'est
aussi un postier un avenir je pense tous
à toulouse la semaine prochaine et au
niveau du budget formation en alternance
est justement la tendance à un média
aussi au pays des passes pendant le mois
et si tu as quoi jouer peut-être une
aide de la famille justement je suis
venu ici pour essayer d'obtenir une note
rides ou nappey trou d oyo non plus le
clash peut aider à trouver un logement
et de demander l'allocation de la caf
il détaille aussi les aides de la ctm
prêt à taux zéro jusqu'à 3000 euros
subvention jusqu'à 1500 euros
différents organismes existent également
pour avancer le dépôt de garantie pour
un studio et même servir de caution
encore faut-il connaître leur existence
si vous êtes étudiant vous avez un petit
budget vous n'êtes pas seuls
notre démarche c'est d'inciter les
jeunes à construire leur parcours
professionnel de faire des études
d'acquérir des diplômes pour être
vraiment compétitif sur le marché de
l'emploi
l'an dernier près de 6 millions d'euros
de subventions ont été accordées aux
étudiants par la ctm qui étudie en
martinique qu'en métropole ou à
l'étranger
toutes ces informations sont
centralisées sur le site claj tirer
martinique point fr